ils et elles se prénomment et blanche
isaac thérèse michel sarrat moïse
paulette ils et elles ont été des
milliers d'enfants avoir été poussé dans
un train sur ce qu'est et le jamais
revenir
cette gare c'était celle de pithiviers
que jouxte l un des deux camps du loiret
où furent internés 16000 des juifs
raflés par la police française sous le
régime de vichy il maréchal pétain
cela avait commencé par une première
grande rafle des juifs étrangers réfugié
en france essentiellement des hommes
puis à l'issue de la deuxième grande
rafle du vel d'hiv
on a interné à pithiviers
essentiellement des femmes et des
enfants et ça a été un internement
terrible très dramatique
d'abord dans des conditions matérielles
effroyable puisque rien n'avait été
prévu pour accueillir une telle masse
d'enfants il y avait les enfants qui
n'avaient pas deux ans et puis ces
enfants parce qu'on a décidé de déporter
d'abord les adultes ont été cruellement
séparés de leur mère est lassé des
scènes comme disait témoin abominable
qu'on rappelle au musée mémorial à
orléans
et puis ces enfants dans la deuxième
quinzaine du mois d'août 42 ont été
déportés d'ici même de ce qu'est la et
aurait été envoyé à auschwitz d'où aucun
est revenue aujourd'hui après que le
centre d'études et de recherche sur les
camps d'internement du loiret le cercil
et ramener la mémoire de ces victimes
dans l'histoire de france
la sncf s'est associé au cercil au
mémorial de la shoah pour réhabiliter la
gare et en faire un lieu de mémoire sur
le plan moral sur le plan
de la préservation des sites de la
déportation c'était absolument
indispensable de pouvoir préserver ce
lieu et puis sur le plan pédagogique
c'est toujours très important de pouvoir
aussi montrer concrètement des lieux
tels que celui-ci des lieux
emblématiques
d'autant plus qu'il n'ya plus rien des
camps de pithiviers et de beaune la
rolande qui sont pourtant à quelques
dizaines de mètres de cette gare
nous avons les photos mais cette gare
finalement pourra témoigner de la
déportation des juifs de france
depuis les camps du loiret c'est dans le
hall de la gare qu'un espace de 200
mètres carrés sera consacrée à rappeler
l'histoire
dehors les rails sont toujours là sur
lesquels roulèr des convois vers
auschwitz